Je n'oublierai jamais
la voix de ma mère juste avant que je m'endorme.
Et je n'oublierai jamais le bruit réconfortant de l'eau
coulant dans un ruisseau.
Imaginez ma peur, ma peur absolue
quand, à l'âge de 10 ans,
on m'a dit que j'allais perdre l'ouïe.
Au cours des cinq années qui ont suivi,
cela a progressé jusqu'à ce que je sois déclarée atteinte
de surdité profonde.
Mais je crois que perdre mon ouïe
a été l'un des plus beaux cadeaux que j'ai jamais reçus.
Je peux expérimenter le monde d'une façon unique.
Je crois que toutes ces expériences uniques
que vivent les gens handicapés
nous aident à créer et à concevoir un monde meilleur
pour tous -- pour les personnes atteintes ou non de handicap.
J'étais avocate spécialisée en droit des handicapés
et, longtemps, j'ai fait appliquer la loi,
m'assurant que les aménagements étaient faits.
Puis j'ai dû rapidement apprendre la politique internationale
car on m'a demandé de travailler sur la convention de l'ONU
qui protège les personnes ayant un handicap.
En tant que dirigeante de l'ONG,
je dépensais mon énergie à essayer de convaincre les gens
des capacités qu'ont les personnes atteintes d'un handicap.
Mais, en cours de route,
et après de nombreuses changements de carrière
qui n'ont pas rendu mes parents très heureux --
(Rires)
je suis tombée sur une solution
qui, je le crois, pourrait être un outil encore plus puissant
pour résoudre les plus grands problèmes mondiaux,
handicap ou non.
Cet outil s'appelle le design thinking.
Le design thinking est un processus d'innovation et de résolution de problème.
Il y a cinq étapes.
La première est la définition du problème
et la compréhension de ses contraintes.
La seconde est l'observation des gens en situation réelle
et être en empathie avec eux.
Trois, jeter des centaines d'idées -- plus il y en a et plus elles sont folles,
mieux c'est.
Quatre, le prototypage : réunissez tout ce que vous pouvez,
tout ce que vous trouvez,
pour modéliser votre solution, pour la tester
et pour la raffiner.
Finalement, l'implémentation :
s'assurer que la solution trouvée est viable.
Warren Berger dit que le design thinking nous apprend à regarder de côté,
à recadrer, à raffiner, à expérimenter
et, probablement le plus important,
à poser ces questions idiotes.
Les spécialistes croient que tout le monde est créatif.
Ils croient en la réunion de personnes issues de différentes disciplines
car ils veulent partager plusieurs perspectives,
les réunir et finalement les fusionner
pour créer quelque chose de nouveau.
Le design thinking est un outil si performant et volatile
qu'il a été appliqué à presque toutes les industries.
J'ai vu le potentiel qu'il avait pour les problèmes que je rencontrais,
j'ai donc décidé de retourner à l'école
et d'obtenir un master en design social.
Il s'agit de réfléchir à comment utiliser le design
pour créer un changement positif dans le monde.
Quand j'étudiais,
je suis tombée amoureuse de la menuiserie.
Mais j'ai rapidement réalisé
qu'il me manquait quelque chose.
En travaillant avec un outil,
juste avant qu'il ne se retourne contre vous --
que l'objet ou l'outil ne vous revienne dessus --
cela fait un bruit.
Et je ne pouvais pas l'entendre.
J'ai donc décidé :
pourquoi ne pas régler ce problème ?
Ma solution a été une paire de lunettes de sécurité
qui ont été conçues pour visuellement alerter l'utilisateur
des changements dans le bruit créé par l'outil,
avant que l'oreille humaine ne l'entende.
Pourquoi est-ce les designers d'outils n'y avaient-ils pas pensé avant ?
(Rires)
Deux raisons. La première : j'étais une débutante.
L'expertise et la sagesse conventionnelle ne pesaient pas sur mes épaules.
La seconde : j'étais sourde.
Mon expérience unique du monde m'a aidée à trouver ma solution.
En avançant, j'ai continué à en trouver d'autres
qui étaient, à l'origine, destinées à des personnes handicapées
et qui ont été reprises,
adoptées et adorées par tout le monde,
handicapés ou non.
C'est un économe OXO.
Il a été conçu pour les personnes atteintes d'arthrite
mais il était si confortable que tout le monde l'a aimé.
A l'origine, les SMS ont été conçus pour les personnes sourdes.
Comme vous le savez, tout le monde adore.
(Rires)
Je me suis dit :
et si nous changions de point de vue ?
Et si nous concevions d'abord pour les handicaps --
pas pour la norme ?
Comme vous le voyez, quand nous concevons d'abord pour les handicaps,
nous tombons souvent sur des solutions qui ne sont pas seulement inclusives
mais aussi souvent meilleures que celles conçues pour la norme.
Cela m'enthousiame
car cela signifie que l'énergie nécessaire pour aider quelqu'un
atteint d'un handicap
peut être multipliée, moulée et nous pouvons jouer avec
et la voir comme une force pour la créativité et l'innovation.
Cela nous fait passer d'une mentalité où l'on essaye de changer les cœurs
et d'une mentalité de tolérance,
à celle d'un alchimiste,
le genre de magicien dont ce monde a désespérément besoin
pour résoudre certains de ses plus gros problèmes.
Je crois aussi
que les personnes ayant un handicap ont un fort potentiel de designer
dans ce processus de design thinking.
Sans le savoir, depuis un très jeune âge,
j'en suis une, je perfectionne mes compétences.
Les spécialistes du design thinking par nature, solutionnent des problèmes.
Imaginez écouter une conversation
et ne comprendre que 50% de ce qui est dit.
Vous ne pouvez pas demander aux gens de répéter chaque mot.
Vous ne feriez que les embêter.
Sans m'en rendre compte,
ma solution a été de prendre le son étouffé que je connaissais,
un battement,
et d'en faire un rythme à placer sur les lèvres que je lisais.
Des années plus tard, quelqu'un m'a dit que mon écriture aussi avait un rythme.
C'est parce que je vis les conversations comme étant des rythmes.
Je suis également devenue très très bonne à échouer.
(Rires)
Littéralement.
Mon premier semestre d'espagnol, j'ai eu 7/20.
Mais j'ai appris que, si je me reprenais
et changeais certaines choses,
je finissais par réussir.
Similairement, le design thinking encourage les gens à échouer
et à échouer souvent
car, finalement, vous réussirez.
Très peu de grandes innovations
sont issues d'un succès au premier essai.
J'ai également vécu cela en sport.
Je n'oublierai jamais mon coach disant à ma mère :
« Si seulement elle n'avait pas sa perte d'audition,
elle serait dans l'équipe nationale. »
Et ce que mon coach et moi ignorions à l'époque
était que ma perte d'audition m'aidait à exceller en sport.
Quand vous perdez votre audition,
non seulement vous adaptez votre comportement,
mais vous adaptez aussi vos sens physiques.
Un exemple
est que mon champ de vision a augmenté.
Imaginez un joueur de football, arrivant par l'aile gauche.
Imaginez être gardien, c'était mon poste,
et la balle arrive par l'aile gauche.
Une personne ayant une audition normale aurait cet angle de vision.
Je bénéficiais d'un champ de vision aussi large que cela.
Je voyais les joueurs
qui bougeaient et s'approchaient de moi.
Je les voyais plus vite, donc si la balle était passée,
je pouvais me repositionner pour être prête pour ce tir.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
j'ai pratiqué le design thinking presque toute ma vie.
Mes capacités d'observation se sont aiguisées,
et donc je vois des choses
que d'autres ne voient pas.
Mon besoin permanent de m'adapter a fait de moi une super idéatrice
et solutionneuse de problèmes.
Et j'ai souvent dû le faire en ayant des limitations et des contraintes.
C'est quelque chose que les designers doivent également faire souvent.
Récemment, mon travail m'a menée à Haïti.
Les pratiquants du design thinking cherchent souvent des situations extrêmes
car cela leur permet de trouver leurs meilleurs designs.
Haïti était un désastre.
J'ai vécu et travaillé avec 300 personnes sourdes
qui ont été relocalisées après le tremblement de terre de 2010.
Mais cinq ans et demi après,
il n'y avait toujours pas d'électricité ;
il n'y avait toujours pas d'eau potable ;
il n'y avait toujours pas de travail ;
il y avait une forte criminalité qui restait impunie.
Des organisations d'aide internationale sont venues, une par une.
Mais elles venaient
avec des solutions prédéterminées.
Elles n'étaient pas prêtes à observer et à s'adapter
selon les besoins de la communauté.
Une organisation leur a donné des chèvres et des poules.
Mais ils n'ont pas réalisé
la famine que vivait la communauté.
Quand les sourds sont partis dormir et ne pouvant pas entendre,
des personnes se sont introduites dans leurs jardins et leurs maisons
et ont volé les poules et les chèvres,
il n'en est pas resté une seule.
Si cette organisation avait pris le temps
d'observer les personnes sourdes, d'observer la communauté,
ils auraient compris leur problème
et auraient peut-être trouvé une solution,
par exemple de la lumière solaire,
éclairer un enclos sécurisé pour les y mettre la nuit
et assurer leur sécurité.
Pas besoin de pratiquer le design thinking
pour avoir les idées que j'ai partagées avec vous aujourd'hui.
Vous êtes créatif.
Vous êtes un designer --
tout le monde en est un.
Laissez les gens comme moi vous aider.
Laissez les personnes handicapées vous aider à regarder de côté
et, en faisant cela,
résoudre quelques grands problèmes.
C'est tout. Merci.
(Applaudissements)